hey everybody welcome to episode 10 of
the 13 o'clock podcast
today we're talking about nazis yeah
everybody loves the nazis [ __ ] nazis
man
specifically we're talking about
the occult beliefs the possible occult
beliefs of the nazis and how it kind of
uh
influenced their ideology allegedly
yeah it's a huge subject and we're not
really sure how we can cover it we don't
think we can cover
all of it in one episode so we'll
probably just start at the beginning of
the whole thing
uh maybe we'll cover a couple different
uh subjects
and um if you guys like this subject we
can revisit it later
yeah because i mean like you said this
is an enormous
topic enormous yeah and you know as we
speak i have like
50 wikipedia pages open like and notes
and stuff
so you know obviously it's just gonna be
as quick so other ways
otherwise we'd be here all night long
but um basically what we kind of wanted
to start with
they think that it kind of started
the whole aryan superiority
mythology let's say if you want to put
it that way
might have started with a book
written by madame blavatsky who was a
russian
aristocrat she wrote this
it was fictional but it was like a
written like a pseudo-history or
pseudo-mythology yeah and she posited
a kind of a race of super beings
that came from atlantis kind of thing
okay so we're going to start on this
topic yeah so what we're doing is we're
going to start with
what we know is true right
and then later certain things were
supposed maybe happened in this subject
you know like i think i think a lot of
this subject actually came
after the 1960s after the nazis were
already gone
because i should say that a lot of the
kind of like nazis were a cultist kind
of stuff
um that in popular culture didn't really
come about until about 1960 when a book
called the morning of the magicians came
out
and that kind of posited a lot of the
stuff that yeah now we're not saying
i mean hitler don't think he was so into
the occult i think he kind of liked to
use the mythology
because he knew it had influence on
people however himmler and hess
might be kind of into that [ __ ] hitler
understood the power of theater he loved
exactly the opera he loved symbolism he
you know he liked it yeah and he
understood
how it could spiritually influence
people exactly
so do i think hitler believed any of
that stuff no now just
now he just believed in its power to uh
inspire i believe yeah yeah that's kind
of where i'm at
it was uh to raise a morale yeah you
know
raise the morale of his country right
because a lot of it so basically
blabotsky puts this book out and it's a
huge
influence on and and at this time in
europe as well as in the united states
um you know kind of end of the 19th
century early 20th century
a big revival in spiritualism yeah it
was across the board
including germany right particularly
because
i mean i think um that was kind of the
beginning of a lot of traditionalist
religion
kind kind of trying to break down
because the origin of species came out
and
more you know science was getting more
play and i think people were kind of
not abandoning traditional religion but
looking for other
options and this goes throughout history
yeah religions don't last long you're
lucky to have a religion last two
thousand years
yeah most of them don't right they they
come into fashion they fall out of
fashion they're replaced by a new one
and this was kind of like the decline of
christianity as a as a like government
type organizations because you know
the age of theocracy is now gone
basically in europe so
they're kind of replacing christianity
with folk beliefs and
supernatural and in some ways going back
to quote unquote
you know golden age golden age kind of
mythology
of you know gods and supermen and things
like that
in a particularly nationalistic
framework well in terms of the germans
in terms of the germans terms of germans
yeah so what ended up happening
uh this this thing that blavatsky wrote
about atlantis and super beings and
stuff like that
was uh it influenced a philosophy or an
idealistic system
called uh theosophy as well as one
called
uh aeriosophy and it's kind of like
i mean her ideas were picked up by
a couple other authors um von list was
one of them
and we're kind of germanized and we're
kind of tied in with german pagan
beliefs right so you know going back to
norse mythology and things of that so
the initial concept of
aryan superman and aryans was not even
german it was a russian concept really
more or less i mean i think she was
drawing on
i mean she was drawing on mythology
right from all over right now to say the
russians weren't germanic a lot of the
russians were germanic so that makes
sense but that seems like where
where that concept first kind of took
root
in the you know in the idea that
later kind of came out in the nazi
ideology
of kind of going back to a racially
superior
super being type of yeah the
idea in general they believed kind of
like um
that humans aren't evolving but they're
devolving that
the ancients used to be giants and they
were you know exactly they were better
than normal people today and they were
trying to re-establish and go back to
the way they were
right right right which is you know that
that even kind of follows some of the
stuff out of
out of the old testament genesis of
nephilim and
yeah yeah it's a similar there's a lot
of parallels super humans and
yeah they're kind of feeling like oh the
longer we go on we're getting
you know race mixing and it was causing
a mongrelization of
these like i said going back to the
golden age
and in the old testament and in the old
testament they're portraying like you
know the early
uh what he called the the early
characters out of the bibles living to
be
800 years old and 400 years old right
you know the patriarchs you know is what
they were and still fathering children
and still bothering children oh yeah
without when they didn't even need
viagra and hot hot
looking 99 year old women that the
all the kings want to mess with yeah
yeah hey man i'm going to be a hot 90
year old man you just wait
so it was just a germanic versions of
that right and that's kind of
where the idea came from and there is
some evidence to suggest
that hitler was kind of into these ideas
i mean these ideas were kind of
you know in the air at the time at least
when he was young at least when
yes when he was very young right um even
before he
he was in world war one right and that
would have that would have been probably
stereotypical for everyone in germany in
the that generation at that time
yeah kind of like people today kind of
know star wars lore and yeah
superman lore right things like that and
then it seemed like
after germany lost the first world war
um it seemed like culturally there was
almost kind of
this sort of shame and this kind of
wanting to re-establish
their power and you know so i think i
can see where
all those kind of occult threads sort of
came together it's like yeah we need to
go back to the old days when we were
yeah
you know and no one no one can
no one can really deny that germany
wasn't royally screwed over
after world war one yeah they were they
were they were mistreated
no no defeated country be treated that
way in the modern age really right
the way germany was treated but so i can
see why they were mad
yeah so yeah they were mad so
basically what we wanted we kind of
wanted to cover
um you know we're kind of talking about
the thule or thule society i've heard it
pronounced both ways
this just for let's just call it a thule
i think most people call it yeah i'm
just saying
i've heard it pronounced the other way
too i don't know if i don't even know if
that's correct
but um and the vril
society yeah this this is where it gets
fought
now i should note that there is really
no evidence that these two societies
ever existed um
some writers have put forth that they
that these societies
they were kind of occult societies
almost like a was it like a freemasonry
kind of thing i want to say because yeah
i would say it was kind of like a
mixture of like a secret society yeah
like
like kind of like the freemasons and uh
mixed with uh
spiritualism yeah fortune telling and uh
you know card reading and things like
that yeah but their own versions of it
they were using runes
real magic yeah which frill made
which von list was uh was a big rune
advocate that's probably where that came
i don't think the real society existed
no i thought that maybe the thule
society existed
is there is there concrete evidence for
it not real sure about that it seems
like no but then some writers say yeah
because the germans totaled modern
germans totally disavowed this they say
that these societies did do not exist or
did not
yeah that they were invented later
afterwards by
by former s by a certain former ss
member
who wasn't high ranking that he made
this up or at least started
right started this these concepts about
old societies
yeah it doesn't seem to be no one can
can
no one seems to agree on this yeah it
was kind of
it seems like most scholarship says that
there was an actual
fool society and it was um formed
right after world war one okay and its
aim
was you know to return germany to you
know a golden age of civilization
after their loss in world war one
and they named it thule or thule
um after a mythical country
from greek legend it was an island
actually an island yeah
it was basically an alternate story for
atlanta atlantis yeah there's a lot of
atlantis kind of stuff going on in here
too
and um and apparently the uh
the organization known as the the thule
society of the soul society
uh was kind of the it was kind of the
nascent uh german workers party and they
think that hitler may have attended one
of the meetings and whatnot then it
eventually evolved into the sa
right which were the nazi storm troopers
which was kind of like a
private army that private unarmed army
yeah that supported the nazi party get
them into power i have to say that um
there the historian nicholas goodrick
clark
who uh wrote that book the occult
history of the nazis or whatever it was
called
yeah i want to say but um yeah he wrote
kind of the definitive book on that in
1985
and he says yes there probably was a
theory decided maybe hess was a member
uh but that he doesn't there's no
evidence that hitler ever
was at any of their meetings right but
um
basically we wanted to talk about that a
little bit and also about
vril yeah vril's fun that's when you get
into the sci-fi version of it yeah
yeah so let's actually let's kind of
talk about that a little bit because
like i said this way but one thing about
the fuel society though is their imagery
didn't
did include a swastika yeah now
swastikas were used
throughout the ages by many different
cultures they even the koreans used it
yeah
and there's in general it's
i would say it's equivalent to to the
yin yang side yeah
it's uh it's it's like four wins four
wins
another description i've heard was is
that the nazi or hitler's interpretation
of it
evidently was that it it was like the
yin yang side
but it represented the axis upon which
the world turned
right and of course the axis powers were
named after that
yeah so the world turns on
change and change is always
like create the cycle of creation and
destruction
to create something you must destroy to
create a house you must cut down trees
that kind of thing so that made a sense
to me it was a black axis upon which the
world turns they're calling themselves
the axis
yeah that they're going to change the
world yeah uh along with you know
italy and japan right and that it was on
a white disk
to symbolize purity and on a red
and then that was on a red background
which represented the blood
of the martyrs that died
in the in the line of defending and
promoting
german national socialism right okay
now german national socialism
is the german interpretation really of
marxism
actually and
the the russians were the international
socialists
the germans were the national socialists
were in a way a different interpretation
of basically the same thing in a way
but that's another subject and that's a
very big subject maybe we can cover that
yeah like i said
the russians had the hammer and sickle
evidently hitler
believed that that was a very powerful
symbol it was a great marketing tool
and uh he decided that that swastika
would was equally impressive to look at
so they chose that one right now whether
or not they got that from the thule
society or the full society
we don't know yeah evidently the the
society used the round swastika
yeah possibly yeah and
we also want to cover a little bit like
i said on
vril of the braille society now there's
no evidence that the royal society ever
existed
no i don't think the real society but
the idea of
vril actually came from a novel
it was written in 1871 it was initially
published as
the coming race but later um reprinted
as vril
the power of the coming race and it was
written by edward bulwer leighton
who uh was actually a very very popular
writer at the time he's probably best
known nowadays
um because he coined popular phrases the
pen is mightier than the sword
and there's also a yearly novel writing
competition well a shitty
novel writing competition that's named
after him just because he's the first
one to use the cliched phrase it was a
dark and stormy night
but he wrote this book called vril the
power of the coming race
and it's kind of like
what happens it's kind of a sci-fi sort
of novel and
they basically these people they go it's
it's hollow earth it's based on the
hollow earth
ology some guys go to a mine they fall
down into a shaft
one of them gets killed the survivor
meets a race of super beings that live
down there they've been down there for
for a long time they escaped the flood
right
and they had the power of vril
the people were called the brilliant
yeah right
navrill was an energy that they could
channel through themselves
yeah to create or destroy they could
heal or destroy
they they could even transmit
information
in other words like telepathy using it
and it kind of sounds like the force or
psychic powers
yeah it's similar to the force now in
the book i believe they uh
they called it like a fluid or some kind
of there's a reason for this
yeah okay the reason was that the author
in his own words
was actually describing electricity
right he thought he
he's riding in like 18 in 1871
and uh they knew about electricity but
they didn't know what was possible with
electricity
so he imagined that electricity could
give you psychic powers
and i wish yeah that's kind of cool now
later on this seems to have
evolved into another concept called
of a substance called orgone you know
which is something that flowed through
the ether and you could
you could or some people could uh
channel it
and cause orgone to create objects to
make energy
and matter and it all came from the
from uh basically a misunderstanding of
electricity
yeah now um that's kind of funny
i guess you know i guess we don't know
much about electricity electricity would
seem to be paranormal
well yeah yeah i'm sure it did at first
right
i mean because it's not i mean it's not
something that it's not real obvious
yeah it's not an obvious visible yeah
and they thought it was a fluid because
electricity flows in a current right so
it goes from one place to the next
so it must be a liquid a fluid
in the ether an invisible fluid that's
why they
it's b that's why vril is being
described as a
liquid yeah kind of strange but then
later on they start
describing anything that gives you
sustenance as
real yeah like real beef
you know and real elixirs
well incidentally if you're from the uk
and you get that stuff i think what what
the hell is it it's like it's i think
it's like beef bouillon or
maybe not yeah is it or like a drink mix
or you live
i know but i can't remember what it is
but it's called boveril and actually the
vril at the end of that is actually
yeah yeah sustenance yeah electricity it
actually comes from that it's electric
cow
electric it might be a drink mix like
quick i
can't i can't actually remember at the
moment i don't feel like looking it up
okay you guys know what i'm talking
about
but um so there were rumors
that that there was a real society that
was kind of based on these ideas
and related to this idea
i mean and there are pictures online
like that show
these women that were supposedly in the
real society they all had super super
super long hair
yeah they were like psychics yeah they
didn't cut their hair went down almost
to the floor
and i read that mate that this long hair
was supposedly so
aliens could communicate with them yeah
so like real maidens
like like like an antenna type of thing
they were they were like
they were like uh they were psychics
yeah you know mediums and evidently they
could
uh talk to aliens and tell you what the
aliens were doing
now nobody knows that this group really
exists right or existed
it probably didn't and weren't there
also rumors that
the third reich actually made um
that they actually went to antarctica
looking for a hole in the earth
like because they thought that there was
something in there i think it's a legend
i don't think they actually did that
although i have to mention right here
that we saw the raddest
horror movie about this very concept yes
nazis at the center of the earth if you
have not seen
go see it right now at the centers of
the earth it is so
awesome it will explain everything
but if you see nazis at the center of
the center of the earth that's
i mean that was actually like some
rumors circulating about
about that yeah vril was uh
real the coming race actually was the
inspiration for nazis at the center of
the earth but you got to see the movie
it's absolutely hilarious it's great
it's fantastic yeah it is really good
there's there's even a real flying
saucer in it there is yeah there is
but we can't spoil it gotta keep moving
yeah i was good i was gonna say oh
two words but i'm like no i'm not gonna
say it's one of the best movies of all
time it is it's awesome
um let me actually let me take a break
right now because we're 20 minutes
because i have to do three breaks this
time sorry about that everybody
but so we're going to take a break right
now and more sponsors yeah more sponsors
and then we will come back and continue
our fascinating discussion
i would like to take a second and thank
subculture corsets and clothing for
sponsoring project i radio and my show
while listening to my podcast please
take a second and visit their website at
www.subculturecorsets.com
they carry a wide selection of corsets
rockabilly gothic steampunk and pin-up
clothing shoes and accessories
again their website is
subculturecorsets.com
or if you're in the jacksonville florida
area stop by their store in the avenues
mall
and if you like to save money use the
discount code 13 o'clock
when checking out and save 10 off your
entire order
by the way if you're a curvy girl
subculture did not forget about you
they carry size 4 to 4x and guys they
have men's clothing and shoes as well
so go shop at subculturecorsets.com now
and use the discount code
13 o'clock for a 10 discount
okay so we were talking about real
maidens yes we were talking about brill
maidens
i don't think real maidens existed no
like i said i think
the uh possible reality of the verl
society came from
this book the morning of the magicians
uh
from 1960 which was kind of um
it was like an overview of all kind of
you know magical and occultist kind of
stuff
but um you know they're talking about
giants ruling the earth and
nazca lines and blah blah um you know a
lot of
conspiracy theory type stuff about the
nazis and
so i think that's where this that idea
came from
i don't the german historians say there
was no real society matter of fact they
removed the
wikipedia page for that yeah okay they
don't allow that one they say that no
that did not happen
and that these put photographs of these
pretty real maidens with the long hair
or random pictures of just girls with
long hair
long hair from the time put together and
then uh people have photoshopped up or
probably just doctored old photos to
make it look like they were
something mysterious had happened in
germany right and you know
yeah and there was there there was even
a woman uh maria orsic
i don't believe she existed right who
was supposed to be the head of it she
was supposed to be a medium and all this
other stuff
some people believe that that that was a
real person that and that she uh
and the photos they show over you know
it's a beautiful woman but for all we
know that's just a model
yeah that could be anybody that could be
anybody and they you know there's a lot
of legends around her but
yeah she doesn't seem to exist which
doesn't seem like
no i mean like i said i've seen the
photos of the same photo you have it's
pretty much
just one photo that's a good idea
whoever made up that legend
it did a good job it's a good idea yeah
yeah but uh i don't think it
it didn't happen though i don't think no
probably not
probably not um we also kind of wanted
to talk about i wanted to talk about
um himmler a little bit because
yeah you got it he seems kind of like
almost like the engineer of a lot of the
kind of occult
stuff surrounding the nazis he seemed
like a true believer hitler i don't
think was
no but if there was if there was a nazi
a cult he would be the one
yeah he'd be the one you go to you know
he was leader of the ss
yeah and uh he ended up getting
possession of
evilsburg castle and made it the main
training center for
ss officers and it did have some cool
stuff that they built down in the
basement uh
a room that had a black sun in the
bottom yeah that was the general's hall
had the black the black sun
symbol and there were uh pedestals where
they were going to put
statues to fall and nazi heroes based on
camelot
or king arthur kind of like that
roundtable type of thing and uh the
the the signet rings of fallen ss
soldiers were going to be
stored there it was a cool idea uh
he's like a sith temple like a sith
temple
but you know that's really not that
unusual militaries
do that they do that kind of stuff today
they're ritualistic when i was in the
army we did
things that were kind of like that yeah
you had unit traditions and
soldierly type traditions that involve
ceremony and pomp that's just the way it
is
yeah because it helps morale it boosts
morale yeah
it gives you kind of a spiritual union
with
the unit and the mission so it's not
very unusual what they were doing uh i'm
sure the citadel and military colleges
in the united states have similar
yeah i mean uh universities have it with
skull and bones
yeah society societies and things like
that so just like is that
now didn't hitler i mean when when he um
established the you know the castle at
bevelsburg
didn't he want to make it you know not
just an ss training
area but also kind of a school where he
would teach them about
uh germanic history or pseudo-history i
should say
i'm sure like a gonna be all kinds of
little indoctrination
you know courses and it was evidently
set on
what he considered to be ley lines and
yeah because he did want that because it
was
uh uh uh supernaturally significant
right well the ss the ss were kind of
like
they were kind of like the uh the
warrior priest class
of of the german forces
uh you know they they had the deaths
head which would you know
symbolize their power of life and death
over
enemies and i i guess germans you know
domestic enemies
enemies foreign and domestic you know
that kind of stuff and um
you know uh it was just a cool castle
i mean wouldn't you want a castle yeah
it is pretty rad yeah
they were gonna have a school there but
no no i don't really
see it as too unusual spooky yeah it was
only spooky because it was
the german
it nationals nazis they had those suits
those black
hugo boss designed uniforms you know
they they they were sharp dressers you
know
everything was pr right they had good
and i have to say
that you know even though the nazis were
giant shitlords
they looked fantastic and it was no
accident
yeah dr joseph goebbels minister
propaganda and
his boys yeah they had all yeah how do
we project
you know an image of strength and power
and then that's what they came up with
they hired the best
designers and graphic designers and
clothing designers and everything looked
cool
and it was really this kind of way of
compensating you know it built morale
yeah it made them look and feel official
and it would uh they got respect from
their enemies by looking
that way yeah looking sharp looking
sharp
every girl crazy about a sharp dress man
i guess so
well they had to compete against the
russians right because the russians were
you know
they had the numerical superiority the
russians had a lot of good weaponry big
armies
you know so they had to project a
uh uh an image of power you know
yeah many different they were in a hard
situation because
the soviet union was none the laugh at
stalin wasn't a nice guy you mean they
had it they started off with a
non-aggression pack but now i'm getting
into history
yeah that's okay getting back to the
economy keep the show fun
i think that honestly i think the reason
why
nazism and occultism is such a
fascinating topic and why so many people
are interested in it
one because you know occult secret
societies everybody loves that [ __ ] i
love that [ __ ]
even if it didn't exist it's still fun
like entertaining to read about
also though i think that some people
because you know some later writers
pseudo-historians let's call them
you know came up with stuff like you
know hitler was possessed by a demon
or you know he went to psychics and
astrologers who told who gave him a
mandrake route
and told him that that meant that he was
gonna
rule the world or whatever and but
honestly i think that
people and you know particularly
starting in 1960 you know when
all of the you know the hitler occult
kind of mythology started
i think that people had such a hard time
you know thinking about how hitler and
the third reich could have done
what they did so it's almost like they
don't want to believe
just regular people could have gone
along with this [ __ ] so they want to
believe like hitler and the and the
third reich were like
magic somehow like they had cast some
kind of magic spell on people to get
them to do these horrible
things or you know you know turn their
head away while horrible things were
going on
so it's kind of that thing where i think
people hang on to supernaturalism
when they're uncomfortable with the lack
of control they have about reality
yeah you know what i mean so i think
there might be an aspect of that like
why people want to believe all these
weird
occult conspiracy theories about the
nazis yeah
but really when you analyze it the only
thing that was unusual about the nazis
was the fact that
they they of the holocaust the holocaust
and this is not a
third world country that did it right
this was a western country that was
highly developed
that's the only thing that was unusual
right things like this
happen in other countries oh yeah all
the time yeah
just not on that scale not using
industrial technology yeah not with guys
because that was kind of the first time
that people in the west had seen that
and i think they had a hard time dealing
with it well
also you have to you have to remember
you have to take into effect and take
okay here's a good analogy
do you remember what it was like back in
the 80s and the 70s how different the
thinking was
yeah it's changed totally yeah all right
well
germany in the 40s wasn't like the rest
of the west in the 40s evidently
evidently germany in the 40s and the 30s
kind of resembled their thinking was
very kind of late late 1800s
yeah they believe in tradition they
believed in the old-fashioned ways
so the third reich wasn't really
even though it was futuristic okay the
third reich wasn't really happening in
the 1940s on a psychological level it
was actually happening
in a futuristic v version of the
late 1800s that's actually a very
insightful way of putting
that's what it was that's how they
thought because their whole shtick
even though they were like looking
toward the future they were actually
looking toward the future
in the sense of going back to a past
like i was saying before
and that's very common in reactionary
movements wanting to go back to some
rose-tinted past that never actually
existed and in their case they kind of
made it into a whole mythology yeah well
imagine that
a good way to look at the german
national socialists is
imagine you got some guys in the late
1800s
imagining a high-tech world right
that's what that's what the german
national socialism in the 1940s and
1930s was yeah
it was a fantasy world yeah
their their mentality was the mentality
of the
late 1800s but their technology was
right mid-1900s yeah 1940s
yeah so in one way they were retro and
another way they were futuristic they
were back to the future
damn
we have to imagine we have to measure
back so they were they were just a weird
mixture of futuristic and retro
they were retro futuristic like
steampunk there yeah
it's the future but it's the past at the
same time it's blowing your mind it's
blowing your mind well they have jets
but then they're they're they're
thinking about you know
like nightly orders and blood you know
and you know it's such a weird just
juxtaposition
when you think about it yeah germanic
blood and
holy causes and this the whole thing is
kind of
has elements of holy crusade to what
they're doing well like i said and
that's why
i mean there were so many rumors
swirling around that you know the nazis
sent expeditions to find the holy grail
yeah uh the spear of destiny which they
actually got that
well you know they got what is it called
the hofsburg spear
yeah then they get it steal it from a
museum in austria yeah you can tell that
story
yeah um we just went around basically
grabbing
anything of historical importance that
wasn't nailed down but that's not that
unusual either
right all armies do that when they go
into a certain area they'll go
to the museums and they'll clear them
out they have to yeah or the looters
will get that stuff or it'll be
bombed or yeah burned down and you know
during firebombings and stuff so
although some of it they haven't found
well they hit it yeah
they'll eventually find it although i oh
i should recommend um
the book the monuments men i don't i
didn't see the movie because i heard it
sucked
but the book is really awesome that that
was kind of about the allied um
group that it was their job after the
war to go and try and find all the
artwork
that uh that the nazis stole very good
book although
one thing that's funny about all the the
missing artwork
we're getting away from the subject was
um that's okay
carmen goring yeah carmen goring would
had had his palace he'd dress up as a in
a toga evidently and have all these
great european artworks all around if
you get drunk in there anybody laying
there and pretending like have someone
feed him grapes
yeah like he was a roman emperor it was
funny oh dear god at least that's the
legend although didn't oh
and also i wanted to mention this too
didn't himmler think that he was the
reincarnation of some ancient kangaroo
yeah uh king heinrich
right he believed in reincarnation and
that's how that i guess that's how he
was
rationalizing how he got to his position
because he went from chicken farmer
yeah to leader of you know commander of
the ss you know right so
well i must have been uh king in a prior
life a germanic king
yes king heinrich that's it which is
like saying you're king arthur
yeah and actually there were kind of a
lot of parallels between the king arthur
story and the
and the whole nazi mythology too the
aryan mythology
although you know it must be said that
patton believed he was reincarnated i
think he
if i remember correctly it was either
some kind of greek soldier
that fought with dave uh fought with uh
alexander but don't quote me on that
that's just off the top of my head
okay he believed in uh george patton
believed in reincarnation
yeah okay so yeah it was
beliefs of the time okay some people
still believe that today
well yeah so that's all right yeah well
actually we kind of we did a show about
it
or about this about those twin girls
that responsibility yeah
it could be i don't know i doubt it but
just gotta wait and see
all right we'll find out later what i'm
gonna do uh i'm gonna take another break
right now
and then when we come back since we were
just talking about uh
you know their technology and stuff like
that let's kind of get into some of the
nazi ufo okay all right because this is
this is yours
i like this one you like this kind of
topic yeah all right so we're gonna take
our second break right now and then
we'll be right back
me
buttercup of doom on project i radio
i am your host kelly owen i'm just a
girl
a girl who writes horror and thriller
fiction talks to bugs jumps in puddles
and now hosts a weekly podcast full of
opinions
advice and a touch of gypsy wisdom
whether it's current affairs or social
media nightmares
join me the buttercup of doom mondays
on project i radio
all right nazis and aliens
okay nazis and aliens where do you where
do you want to
go with this yeah nazis didn't have
anything to do with aliens well no i
know but
during that time all of the uh
all the armies were looking at flying
discs
but maybe not in the way that people
would think uh
the the us the us was working on
something called the flying flapjack
which was a disc shaped aircraft that
had propellers
out on the outside of the disk and it
was nearly vertical landing and takeoff
and they uh they built several of those
and
the last version of it was actually a
combat
prototype had guns on it and everything
but they wanted that to uh
use on aircraft carriers because you
could put a lot of them up there on a
flight deck and you didn't need a real
you didn't need a lot of room yeah for
the things that take off
but they scrapped it because uh the jet
age
came and it got to be where they could
land a jet on an aircraft carrier
now weren't we watching videos of that
flying flapjack thing and it just
never really uh oh the flying flapjack
worked
did it yeah it worked but maybe i'm
thinking about it they scrapped it
they scrapped it you can look it's
called the voigt
flying flapjack um we can show them a
photograph of it on youtube
now uh the germans were also working
with vertical ladding and takeoff
because their runways were getting
bombed
and one of the weirdest ones that they
were working on was called the triflugal
the triflugal was like a an aircraft was
shaped like a cigar
and it and it spins on it had fins like
a rocket
and it stood up just like a rocket but
in the central section it had big blades
like a helicopter
and at the end of each blade was a ram
jet
and it would cause the the rotor
assembly to spin
and it could take off straight up and
then it could level out and fly forward
and even flight
kind of like a helicopter a
rocket-powered helicopter
they were working on that but of course
you couldn't land something like that
especially with
1940s technology and uh that didn't go
anywhere but then they were also working
on a
disc shaped aircraft now they were
rumored
to make these things called vril saucers
and flying saucers
but there's no surviving actual evidence
there could be some drawings
but i'm not i i'm not sure those have
been totally
verified as authentic drawings of of a
real flying saucer yeah i'm not really
sure if
they actually believed that they're
because there were rumors
that they were employing alien
technology
or we're building things with this real
power or we're experimenting with time
travel
absolutely why would the aliens be
interested in the nazis
maybe the islands are nazis too
we don't know anything about the aliens
if aliens were one that
wanted to deal with a terrestrial power
they would have dealt with the united
states
you think because we had the industrial
infrastructure and the wealth because
we're the best obviously
we had a bigger industrial
infrastructure to make that kind of
technology than the germans did they'd
been talking to us
yeah yeah well and russia had all the
manpower everybody likes to think
they're special and they're the ones
that aliens would talk to
no problem i think if there's really
aliens they don't give a [ __ ] about us
now there was rumored to be
a disc shaped aerial gunnery
uh target that they were working on
uh but very little is known about that
and it kind of did look like a flying
saucer but
the way it was described was kind of
like a half of a
sphere with a ring around it
and in that ring was a bunch of little
blades and
and you could fly it up the air on a
remote control and you shoot at it
now i don't know if it's true how the
story goes is that
where they were working on that thing
the russians were advancing
and everyone on that project destroyed
the little prototypes that they had
including
disc shaped aircraft but you know
the collapse the collapse of the third
reich is like something out of mad max
there aren't even accurate records about
what happened and where
things went and just people vanished in
the equipment vanished
things destroyed it it was a it was it
was an apocalypse
now um another weird one was victor
schauberger
and he was working on something called a
repulsing
and a repulsing was a motor
based upon vortex energy oh
all right now we know about jets where
you use
a electric engine to start a bunch of uh
uh to start a
turbine with a bunch of blades on it and
you combust
fuel inside that turbine assembly which
causes it to spin
and when it spins it sucks more air
through the front where it's
mixed with fuel and then the combustion
happens it blows out the back
jet power we know about jet power but
that's not what a repulsing was
there were two different versions of a
repulsing that were
rumored to exist one of the ones that i
remember was cigar shaped
and you could put it inside the fuselage
of an aircraft and you used an electric
motor to spin
this spiral looking
blade assembly thing and when it spun
it caused a vortex to happen similar to
a tornado and once it got up to a
certain speed
it would power itself in a way that a
tornado powers itself
that was called a refulsing another one
was one that was kind of like a flying
saucer shape that would suck air into
the top blow it out through the bottom
once you got it running once you got i
don't understand how it worked
the descriptions of how these things
work if it did if it did indeed work
the descriptions sound wacky but
evidently it was made by
you know victor schallberg who was like
the german version of a
mad scientist basically although you
know he did do some real work so
nobody knows that's what i mean that he
does
what do you know about the nazi bell
the nazi belt was supposed to be this uh
metal bell-shaped object that was
kept underground as at a certain type of
research facility
and it would glow blue and it would
hover and it
poisoned everybody that worked on it and
evidently the russians got their hands
on it at the end of the war
that's but i think that story came from
poland
if i remember correctly there was a uh a
polish writer
was the first person to mention this i
believe it was poland don't hold me to
that that's not the top of my head
the the audience can research that
themselves i don't believe there was a
nazi bell
sorry i don't well what was i mean what
was it supposed to be
powered oh man there are so many
stories about that nazi bell but what it
did that it could bend space time and
allow you to see in the
teacher that it was a propulsion unit
that it could you know that could power
fly of real flying saucer that kind of
stuff
but uh based on the descriptions and the
conflicting accounts that
i don't believe that existed now they
said it was filled
and one account said that it was filled
with mercury that would spin around
inside of it and it would glow blue
the only thing that kind of sounds a
little bit like that mercury
glowing blue might be an ion
engine and you know we use ion drives on
spacecraft yeah like satellites they
don't move fast
you know so it's not like something and
they would put out a lot of ions
i'm sure it would be good for your
health to be around an ion engine
if it was running inside the earth's
atmosphere
now the germans
were interested in exotic propulsion if
a nazi bell existed
if it did which i don't believe it did
but let's say a nazi bell type thing
existed
that caused these rumors may have been
an ion engine which could have made
sense because they were working with
jets too
and maybe that was a natural progression
hey
let's just throw a bunch of ions out the
back and we'll get some thrust
but i think rapidly the germans would
have discovered that there's almost no
thrust out of an ion engine
they'd be like well back to the drawing
board yeah or however you say that you
get a plane to fly with an ion engine i
think would be
next impossible but
the germans weren't real rational you
know uh they kind of had an
anti-rationalist streak in them they
yeah and i actually meant to mention
that that they were actually
as much as as much as they're kind of
known for
doing these wacky not wacky but
these horrible science experiments and
things with the you know human subjects
and
all the stuff they were trying to build
yeah
they were almost anti-science really
even though they wanted to be
technologically powerful remember they
were back to the future like i said
right imagine guys in the 1800s
dreaming up science fiction machines
they were kind of like that but they had
the science to do it
yeah um but they didn't know quite
enough
one of werner von braun's friends i
forgot his name i just coming off the
top of my head
maybe we can uh put a link to him or
something
one of his friends wrote an article in a
magazine and it was
if i remember correctly called oh man
what was it lack of reason or or lack of
reason in nazi land
yeah or scientific oh yeah scientific it
was
it was something like that because i did
yeah i just saw that in my uh
yeah that skimming through wikipedia
even german scientists
believed in things that were not
rational yeah
it's just the culture yeah culture and
it was the times it was hey you know
let's try to make a ray gun
why not yeah why not i mean you know a
single round
a single nine millimeter round that we
use our submachine guns really only cost
two cents but no let's make an expensive
ray gun
now there they would be they would do
something because i think really that
was one of the factors that eventually
led to their downfall because they were
spending all this money
on working on all this weird
[ __ ] that just was never going to work
instead of trying to come up with the
next
best fighter plane they'd try to make 10
of the next best fighter planes each one
of them totally different and some of
them
absolutely ridiculous yeah let's make a
death ray yeah yeah yeah
they were like that let's build the
planet killer well they tried to build a
space shuttle basically
yeah they had a suborbital bomber called
the sanger suborbital bomber
and they were going to launch this thing
off a huge rocket rail in france
have it skip across the top of the
earth's atmosphere and drop a
radioactive dirty bomb on new york
they they tried to do that yeah with
1940s technology it never would have
worked
no and we're going to use a bunch of v2
rockets pushing a sled
let's show it yeah it is bizarre
they were ambitious hey they were
reaching for the stars
they were anti-rationalists
it's a lot better than building a plane
we're going to build a sub orbital
that's no fun no fun yeah it's no fun
okay so i'm going to take my third break
right now
and then we will come back and i don't
know just discuss a few other little
odds and ends
odds and sods as they say in britain
so here's the third break and we'll be
back in just a second
there are terrors real and imaginary and
i write about them all
paranormal non-fiction horror fiction
the mammoth mountain poltergeist the
associated monsters red menace
go to www.jennyashford.com
or search amazon for the jenny ashford
author page
okay so nazis
occultism anything to it what have we
yeah what have we established
um like i said i mentioned uh
himmler before how he was kind of the
the big brains behind this
sort of operation um you know hitler was
not really big into occultism at least
you know when he was young maybe he was
but uh
you know later actually when they
started you know
killing everyone uh occultists were in
that group
yeah they'll kill him and hitler did
publicly denounce
occultism whether because he thought it
was harmful or whether because
he didn't want he didn't want maybe he
didn't want rumors spread around
rumors spread around about his own
beliefs who knows
but um i actually wanted to mention and
i forgot to mention this before i
wanted to mention uh himmler forming the
ana nurby
yeah that's this did happen yeah now
this yeah this actually
did happen and i believe it was uh it
was under the auspices of
of the annan irby that they did all
these kind of archaeological expl
expeditions did they not the annan army
most likely inspired
the story of indiana jones i was just
going to say raiders the lost greatest
yeah where they were looking for the ark
of the covenant looking for the ark of
the covenant
but the anonymity was actually looking
for the origins of the aryans
race right so they go to tibet
yeah that was their way the reason why
they went to tibet is because tibet had
swastikas
on their raises so ooh swastika is here
swastika
is there so they go there to measure the
skulls yeah
all these uh tibetans you know and they
then they declared them aryans yes
they're white people
even though they're not yeah they're not
really i guess i don't know
that's well that's what's so funny it
was not it was a publicity stunt if yeah
well okay what does it say what does it
say there tell us about the another
well basically it was it was just i mean
ana nervy means inheritance from the
ancestors
okay so like you said they were
basically trying to bolster this
nationalist germanic mythology they were
trying to establish
that they were quote you know the master
race and that you know they came from
or or they were like a degraded version
of a past
you know uh super hero type race of
people
so basically they were they were looking
for any kind of
archaeological or cultural information
that would
back that up and uh
so but it also kind of took on occult
overtones because himmler was so into
that kind of thing
but um but that was basically all it was
about just kind of
trying to establish ancestral supremacy
i guess
yeah well i know that i know this is for
true
all right um hitler derided that program
yeah he thought it was a waste of time
they just used it as a pr
stunt he just thought it was silly yeah
and um
there's a film of
home movies of adolf hitler hanging out
with uh
i think it's uh joseph goebbels is one
is there
a couple of his other high party members
and he mentions this in the home film
now the whole movie that he mentions the
ad in erbium
doesn't have sound but they use a lip
reading program
to add or you know to to see what it is
to figure out what he said what he's
saying
and he made a snide comment about yeah
that's about as smart as trying to find
aryan ancestry in tibet you know he just
and then he cracked a joke about
himmler so they were taking the piss out
of hitler himmler a lot
and he also what he also made a joke
about uh he's uh how did it go
and he goes it was along the lines of
eating eating in front of
hermann goring was the time i realized
that pigs eat pork
there is so okay sitting across the
dinner table from
from with uh
i forgot his name what's that cory oh
yeah city sitting across the dinner
table from goring that's the day i
realized that pigs eat pork
that's just hilarious for some reason
it's very amusing to me to think of
nazis sniping at each other like petty
little [ __ ] oh evidently
that's hilarious evidently evidently
they were quite quite the characters and
that's all they did was just take the
piss out of each other constantly
nazis are [ __ ] you guys well um the
third reich wasn't
a top-down uh organization like uh
like the soviet union was hither had a
lot of power
but the way it was structured the third
reich was
basically a bunch of fiefdoms competing
fiefdoms each one run by
popular party bosses that had come up
through the revolution over the years
and each little fiefdom had overlapping
uh responsibilities and they competed
with each other and stole from each
other constantly
yeah it's just bizarre totally
inefficient there's this idea that there
was some kind of a
nazi efficiency like they were
frighteningly kind of
organized no no they're very amateurish
in a lot of infighting and clicky yeah
like like mean girls well
these guys all knew each other you know
they all met each other in a bar
yeah you know they'd get in a bar drink
beer and just you know talk about how
bad the
german republicans were man
people blow it into something that it
wasn't himmler's so flaky these are guys
that just were hanging out in a bar
we're going to take over
they did which is so funny because in
bars all over the world there's probably
dudes getting drunk and saying that all
the time getting over
yeah we're taking over the world all
right that's right god damn we need to
be running this
well they were combat veterans and you
know they ended up getting support
and they actually went down there with
clubs and fists and beat up communists
yeah
and the cops liked them they let them do
it and then the cops started to join
them then next thing you know
the sa and the nazi party was bigger
than the german army yeah it just kind
of so
they became the army and then they took
over and then
they then they started getting rid of
things like elections they just declare
in emergencies
so you know he did it the old-fashioned
way yeah it didn't have anything to do
with
hitler selling his soul to the devil and
the occult of him rising to power
he got into power the same way all those
other guys got into power
from the bottom they just fight their
way to the top although i also wanted
like before
uh we wrap up i also wanted to talk very
briefly
about uh kind of nazi the human
experimentation and
their their desire to perhaps create a
super soldier
oh yeah well that wasn't just them the
soviets were trying to do that too yeah
exactly
yeah but um i mean most people know
now like i said whenever you talk about
actually we did that
yeah we just made meth yeah
they called them pet pills back then
well yeah yeah they give the potatoes
they still give them to pilots today
yeah well yeah they gave them all kind
of illegal drugs back then and they
didn't like it wasn't a secret either
well it wasn't illegal at the time was
it that's what no
it still isn't yeah but um
you know like i said with nazism there's
always this
you know there's there's such a mystique
about them still
that you know the line between reality
and fantasy is kind of blurred
so i mean obviously they live on video
games
yeah like wolfenstein but um
you know obviously they did do human
experimentation with
uh a lot of the prisoners yeah and they
did do weird [ __ ] like let's poison sets
of twins and see which one of them dies
first and
that kind of [ __ ] and then you know
there's other rumors that
you know they tried to was it them that
they tried to impregnate women with
with different animals and stuff or was
that the soviets i was thinking about
okay so like i said there's you know on
a side note
yeah there was a there's a soviet
program
to crossbreed humans with chimpanzees
to make a soldier out of that but it got
abandoned quickly
is it bad that i kind of wish i knew how
that turned out
it didn't i'm curious it didn't work it
didn't work
i mean we're so genetically similar they
wanted to make like a
sub race of human beings that were
really strong because chimpanzees are
really strong and that you could you
know unleash them on the enemy
it was somebody's wacky idea and stalin
said yeah okay try that out
but evidently he killed the program
pretty quickly once they realized that
although that's kind of the thing
how could you control them and kind of
get back to the nazis too it's kind of
like
they want to do all the scientific
advancement but it's almost like they
only knew enough science to come up with
dumb [ __ ] that wasn't going to work
you know what i mean because it's like
yeah they kind of understood evolution
but not in not really because it's like
some of the experiments they were doing
and [ __ ] like that shows that they
really didn't understand it would work
at all
and the thing the thing with the chimps
and human women
either like yeah let's breed chimps and
humans together because it will make a
super strong
person that's still kind of smart but
also kind of animalistic and they were
disposable
right but you have no idea what that
could be what would happen
the genetics is too complicated right
well they want a good they're gonna try
it i mean you know which is why eugenics
doesn't really work either because
like i said the genetic dna is too
complicated to know how shit's gonna
come out
right it's like you might get some good
[ __ ] happening and then all this
negative [ __ ] over here
they wanted to see if they could make a
humanzee a humanzee a human seat yeah
but uh you know so needless to say
the nazis never did create a super
soldier uh they probably didn't weren't
talking to the aliens well this their
super soldier were the it was the voffin
ss
yeah and they did they'd send them send
them to the eastern front they give them
meth
yeah and you could fight for days on
meth yeah
and uh you know that's that's documented
and it had it didn't matter
they had a high casualty rate a low
survivability probability on that
so yeah give them math they'll fight for
four days straight
but they couldn't supply most of those
guys just froze to death
yeah on the eastern front yeah that's
another topic yeah
but uh anyway let's see what what is our
what is our time looking like here oh my
goodness okay we're almost in an hour
okay all right so uh you know like i
said we've just scratched the services
there's
so much enormous enormous topic um you
know if you want to look at anything
look up the thule society look at vril
ariosaphy uh the anna nerby nazi um ufos
there's information all over the place
so we just kind of did a rambling
discussion
yeah if you guys want us to look into
anything else
on this subject just drop a comment yeah
and we can do like a part two or
something
because i feel like i feel like there
was so much that we didn't cover
yeah researching for the show you're
just like oh man it's like reading the
library there's so much of this stuff
that's what i mean yeah it's like this
was actually um
tom had been wanting to have been
wanting to do this topic for a while
and i was like i am not i mean he's
pretty up on his world war two
yeah i love world war ii yeah he's
really into that and i don't know
like i know you know what most people
know about it but i i didn't know a lot
about the nazi and occult thing other
than like a couple dumb documentaries
that's on history the
probable history channel that were
probably [ __ ] so i had to do like a
lot of
research for this so if i [ __ ]
something up i'm sorry but i'm just like
i'm sitting here like looking at like 50
different pages to make sure i'm getting
stuff right
so uh anyways so i guess we're gonna
where i guess we're gonna wrap up
all right all right so if you like the
show um
then make sure to either download us on
iproject radio or
watch our youtube show and subscribe to
our youtube channel
and you know give us a like whatever and
also you can check us out on our
facebook page and our twitter
which is 13 o'clock podcast and
uh that'll probably do it and we we got
to wait
walking dead's on tonight we got to see
who's yes we're recording this on sunday
that's right
it's just four hours from now four hours
from now who is it
who's getting beaten to death by lucille
oh [ __ ]
we don't know um we haven't seen it yet
i'm saying
it's uh glenn glenn's dodged a bullet
too many times it's gotta be glenn i
think it's gonna be abraham and then
glenn
and then rick is gonna get his hand cut
off we'll see
i'll say glenn five dollars he's not
gonna bet on it
or it might be maggie no that that's
wild card no
all right all right glenn he's dodged
the bullet too many times glenn must
die
and on that note thanks for listening to
13 o'clock
and we'll see you next week bye bye
you